Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Frau Dohr, Frau Kaner.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen an einem Nespäche-Brett durchführen.
Kurse Applaus würde ich nach Ihren Daten erfahren.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Joachim Schlefer.
Joachim Schlefer, okay.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname langsam bestabieren?
Ja, der Vordergrund Joachim.
Okay.
Und der Familienname Schlefer, S-C-H-L-A-Umblaut, F-E-R.
Herr Schlefer, wann sind Sie benachgeboren?
Am 17.04.1975.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,83 m.
Ich denke, ich wachse auch nicht mehr.
Und 90 kg bin ich schwer.
Das kann sich natürlich noch ändern.
Herr Schlefer, was für eine Schwärmung sind Sie?
Ich habe ganz starke Schmerzen im rechten Rückenbereich.
Das strahlt aus bis in die Leiste und ins Genital.
Die Schmerzen sind wirklich sehr heftig.
Es ist so, dass ich mich einmal übergeben habe,
weil ich das Gefühl habe, ich kann diesen Schmerzen gar nicht entgegensetzen.
Okay.
Wie lange sind Sie an den Rückenschmerzen?
Ja, vor zwei Stunden.
Sind die Schmerzen plästisch oder langsam angefangen?
Nein, das ist ganz plötzlich gekommen.
Wie lange sind die Schmerzen auf einem Schmerzskoller?
Wobei, nun kann man sie nicht mehr sehen.
Die sind bei 8, würde ich sagen.
Herr Schlefer, haben Sie eine Lage gegen Schmerzmittel?
Nein, ich habe eigentlich nur eine Allergien gegen Bestenstiche
und ich habe eine Laktose in Toleranz.
Aber bei Schmerzmitteln können Sie ruhig etwas geben.
Okay.
Können Sie bis Ende des Geschenks aufhalten?
Oder soll ich Ihnen ein Schmerzmittel verabreichen?
Das wird ja jetzt nicht so lange dauern.
Was sein?
Ich muss vielleicht mal zwischendurch auf die Toilette,
weil ich ständig auf die Toilette muss.
Das tut auch so schrecklich weh, wenn ich auf die Toilette gehe.
Wie würden Sie Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie erheblich, brennend, dumpf?
Es brennt, würde ich sagen.
Im Rücken lassen Sie mehr so krempfe.
Ich sehe einen Auslöser dafür aufgefallen.
Ich sehe einen Auslöser.
Ich sehe jetzt Öbel.
Ja, vor Schmerzen ist mir schlecht.
Okay.
Haben Sie schon gegen Schmerzen etwas Medikamente eingenommen?
Nein, das ist ja gerade erst losgegangen.
Es ist ja noch nicht so lange.
Ich bin dann gleich hierher gekommen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ich habe gerade gesagt beim Wasserlassen,
dass das weh tut und ich ständig zur Toilette muss.
Wie oft gehen Sie zur Toilette?
Normalerweise fahren wir am Tag,
aber jetzt muss ich eigentlich ständig da hinlaufen.
Da kommt immer nur ein bisschen und dann brennt das so stark.
Okay.
Wie fühlen Sie sich allgemein?
Haben Sie viel bei Schüttefrost?
Ich habe jetzt keine Fieber gemessen.
Fühlen Sie sich fieberisch?
Ich fühle mich schlecht und krank, aber fieberisch weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Wie sind Sie mehr?
Eigentlich nicht.
Mir ist vielleicht eher kalt.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Fußauftreten?
Fühlen Sie sich krebelngefühlt in den Beinen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie schon mal solche Bescheiden gehabt?
Nein, das kenne ich überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe nur eine Rücken- und Schmerzen bei der Toilette.
Wo sind Sie immer genau in London?
Nein, eher auf der rechten Seite.
Ich habe nur eine Rücken- und Schmerzen.
Ich habe nur eine Rücken- und Schmerzen bei der Toilette.
Wo sind Sie immer genau in London?
Nein, eher auf der rechten Seite.
Auf der rechten Seite, oberhalb von der Hüfte würde ich sagen.
Haben Sie keine Schüttelgang-Probleme?
Nicht normal.
Ich habe in der letzten Zeit nicht gewollt, ob das so genommen ist.
Das ist immer stabil.
Ich möchte wissen über Ihre Vorerkrankungen.
Leiden Sie an eine Vorerkrankung?
Ja, mein Hausarzt hat festgestellt, dass ich einen hohen Blutdruck habe.
Seit wann leiden Sie daran?
Vor vier Jahren hat man das festgestellt.
Ich nehme immer Tabletten, d.h. Dilltia 1090.
Dann nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Ich hoffe, dass es damit jetzt okay ist.
Dann habe ich noch eine Berufskrankheit.
Ich habe immer wieder Sehentscheiden-Enzündungen im rechten Arm.
Wenn es gerade unangenehm ist, ist es eine Ortese.
Es ist gerade wieder so seit einem Monat, dass es wieder schmerzhaft ist.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nein, die Operation hatte ich noch nie.
Ich habe nur Tabletten, die ich mit dem Blutdruck haben kann.
Ich habe auch keine Schmerzen.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Ich nehme auch eine andere Medikamente.
Wenn es mit den Schmerzen zu sehr ist, in dem Arm, ich muss weiter arbeiten,
dann nehme ich auch mal Ticrofenac oder Nuvalgien.
Aber nicht regelmäßig.
Sind Sie vollständig gegen Kindheit- und Corona-Krankheiten?
Gegen Kinderkrankheiten? Ja, ist ja schon lange her.
Aber da habe ich alle Impfungen, die man so brauchen kann.
Und gegen Corona bin ich auch geimpft.
Ja, klar, dreimal.
Sie haben Naktos in Telleras und sie haben Allergien.
Sie haben ein Werkstoff, ein Erwebend.
Gegen Westpünchtig sind ich allergisch.
Gegen Westpünchtig.
Wie äußert sich die Allergie gegen Westpünchtig?
Ja, ich bin da tatsächlich einmal umgekippt.
Da habe ich einen Schockzustand bekommen.
Deswegen muss ich da sehr aufpassen.
Was bei meinem Beruf schlecht ist, weil ich als Bäcker arbeite.
Da ist das Risiko, dass sich in der Backstube eine Westpüfe ehrt.
Das ist schon groß.
Ja, natürlich.
Rauchen Sie Herzschläcke?
Seit fünf Jahren rauche ich nicht mehr.
Aber früher habe ich ordentlich geraucht.
Ja, das freut mich.
Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, mit dem Rauchen auszuhören.
Wie viele Sekretanrauchen Sie vorher?
Ich habe ein Päckchen am Tag schon geraucht.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Ja, das waren gut 20 Jahre. 22 Jahre habe ich geraucht.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig oder gelegentliche Alkohol?
Ja, am Abend zum Schlafen trinke ich 2-3 Weserbier.
Täglich, meinen Sie?
Ja, das ist ziemlich regelmäßig.
Seit wann trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, wann fängt man damit an?
Früher habe ich natürlich mehr getrunken als junger Mann.
Das war es mit 17, 18, 19, hat noch mehr getrunken.
Aber seit ich in der Ausbildung bin, kann ich mir das nicht mehr erlauben.
Weil ich immer früh aufstehen muss.
Aber ja, vielleicht jetzt, seit ich 20 bin, so ungefähr.
Herr Schäfer, ich möchte wissen, nehmen Sie bitte die Frage nicht weit.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Haben Sie schon mal probiert?
Mit Drogen? Nein, das habe ich noch nie probiert.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, ja, die leben beide noch.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, nicht gesund. Mein Vater hat eine Gefäßertrankung und ein offenes Bein.
Dem ist die rechte Großzehe abgenommen worden.
Aber im Augenblick kommt er so zu Recht.
Meine Mutter ist relativ gesund.
Sie hat Probleme mit der Wirbelsäule.
Sie hat eine Verkrümung von der Wirbelsäule.
Dadurch hat sie oft Schmerzen.
Ihre Mutter hat vielleicht eine Bein-Scheibenvorfall?
Was hat sie?
Bein-Scheibenvorfall?
Nein, sie hat eine verkrümte Wirbelsäule.
Sind Ihre Eltern bluthoch, blutzucker, kranker?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwester.
Sind Sie ein Kind?
Ja.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet, aber ich lebe getrennt von meiner Frau.
Sind Sie schon seit dem Trennungsscherein?
Ja, wir leben getrennt und wir haben Scheidung.
Die Kinder sind bei meiner Frau.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
3.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, die Kinder sind gesund.
Zur Seite leben Sie alleine?
Total, ich lebe alleine.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich habe eine eigene Bäckerei.
Ich arbeite auch im Betrieb selber mit.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Natürlich, ich werde keine Stress bei der Arbeit.
Selbstständige haben immer Stress.
Das ist schon nicht einfach heutzutage.
Ich hatte noch ein paar Fragen.
Sie haben einen brennenden Schmerz beim Solacen.
Wie sieht Ihr Urin aus?
Das ist mir aufgefallen, dass da blutige Spuren drin sind.
Haben Sie geschuldet bei Marc?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ja, Herr Schlepper, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas ins Vögel?
Ja, ich möchte jetzt nur wirklich ganz gerne, dass das irgendwie, dass Sie das möglichst schnell mir sagen, was da los ist und dass Sie was gegen die Schmerzen machen können.
Ja, ich vermute, Sie leiden an Nieren in den Stein oder Handwerksinfekt, aber ich brauche ein paar Untersuchungen um Ihre Diagnose festzuschütteln.
Ich werde die körperliche Untersuchung danach jetzt gleich Ihnen ein Schmerz mitergeben.
Das ist gut, ja.
Danach, wir werden ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Je nach der Ergebnisse von Untersuchungen würde ich Ihre Diagnose Ihnen sicher sagen.
Okay, das klingt doch nach einem guten Plan.
Muss ich denn hier bleiben?
Ja, ich komme Ihnen gleich zurück.
Ja, Sie warten, im Wartezimmer mich.
Ich komme Ihnen gleich.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Kollegen an den Fragen?
Ja, der fragt jemand, ob mir übel war, das hat sie gefragt.
Und ich habe das bestätigt.
Der Patient hat ja gesagt, er hat sich übergeben, weil er solche Schmerzen hat.
Und natürlich ist ihm dann auch schlecht.
Hat noch jemand eine andere Frage?
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhafter oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich würde sagen, Sie pulsieren ein bisschen.
Das ist eine Krämpfe, das ist ein krampfartiges Schmerzen.
Gute Frage.
Also, ich vermute, dieser Patient trinkt viel,
weil bei der Arbeit ja in sehr heißen Räumen unterwegs ist,
der trinkt wahrscheinlich viel Wasser.
Vielleicht ist er auch nicht immer dazu gekommen.
Fieber hat sie gefragt, weiß er nicht, er fühlt sich nicht fieberig.
Ihre Wassalassen riechen.
Das riecht, ich bin nicht aufgefallen, dass das anders riecht.
Können wir anfangen, Arsatzke Schiebre?
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarstein.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen einen neuen Patienten,
Herr Schleffer, vorstellen.
Hatten Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Herr Johann Schleffer ist 75 Jahre alt, 1,83 m groß und 90 kg schwer.
Herr Schleffer, sie teilte sich bei uns wegen vor 2 Stunden,
plötzlich aufgetretener Kraftartikel,
Post-Ränder, Brennländer, Schimmerschen,
im rechten, unternländen Wirtbuseulebereich
mit Ausschütterung in Leistenbereich.
und Herr Schleffer berichtet, dass die Schmerzen von Neusea mit Emesis begleitet wurden.
Die Fragen nach FIBA und Schüttefrost wurden verneilt.
Die vegetative Anamnesi war unauffällig Herr Schleffer klagt über dieseerie und fünfmalige technische Polaköri.
Herr Schleffer ist vorsternig geimpft. Er hat allergien gegen West-Pen-Stationen und mit einer Flakse reagiert.
Er ist ex-Raufer. Vor fünf Jahren hat er mit dem Raufer aufgehört.
Er hat vor zwei Jahren ein Päckchen geraucht.
Er ist bei ihm Artériole Hypertonie bekannt seit vier Jahren.
Er hat 90 mg Tablet, zwei Malen täglich.
Er hat eine Diplofenac oder eine neue Tablet, gegen Seheninsündung.
Er hat einen rechten Arm, eine Überanstrengung.
Er ist ein Erbenes, der in der Familie Anamnesi ist.
Er hat drei Kinder, seine Kinder lebt in der Mutter.
Er ist ein Bezitzer, ein Becker.
Er hat viele Belastung und Stress bei der Arbeit.
Er hat eine Diagnose, die differenzial diagnostisch ist.
Meine Verdachtdiagnose würde ich erst den Patienten kontinuieren.
die einen Klopfschmerzen in rechten Flankenbereich.
Bei Apandicities können ein Abweichspannung im Baubereich finden.
Was finden wir möglicherweise im Zug auf die Nieren noch?
Weil er ja ständig auf die Toilette muss?
Ja, Gloppe, wie kann ich auf Deutsch sagen?
Im Publikbereich kann ich ein Doroktolens wegen Reste haben.
Ich kenne nur den mit dem Glasen hochstand.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das das Gelde ist.
Ja, wie türkisch sagen wir gloppe, aber ich kann mir da nicht.
Vielleicht können wir uns von den Kollegen gleich einer korrigieren.
Was machen Sie denn weiter an Untersuchungen?
Ich werde großes Blutbild, Entschuldungswerte, Urinprobe gegeben.
Ich werde über die Stront-Kann-Aufnahme, die Ebenen...
Was machen Sie erst vor der Abgum-Röntgenaufnahme?
Ein Abtomanssonographie.
Genau.
Was erwarten Sie da?
Bei der Urinprobe erwarte ich Lokosythorie, Erritrocythorie.
Was macht Sie bei der Abtomssonographie?
Abtomssonographie ist nicht einfach, ein Stein, das sich stellen kann.
Wenn der Stein groß ist, können wir mit der Sonographie mit dem Stein.
Aber was können wir unter Umständen sehen?
Vielleicht können wir eine Erweiterung in Harleiter und Hydronephroso-Zeichen.
Das war es.
Bei Urinprobe habe ich schon erzählt.
Bei Harleiter Infektion kann ich ihre Entschuldungswerte erhört sein.
Ich habe mich mit der Sonne verheiratet.
Ich werde mit der Erweiterung in der Sonne verheiratet.
Ich werde mich mit der Sonne verheiratet.
Ich empfehle bei den Patienten viel Wasser trinken.
Und wenn es wegen Neuseher nicht möglich ist, kann ich ein Zugang legen und ein Flüssigkeit...
Flüssigkeit zu viel über Wienlösensugang.
Das ist vielleicht auch nicht schlecht für die Schmerzmittel, wenn man einen Wienlösensugang hat.
Ja, natürlich.
Gegen Neuseher würde ich ein Antimetika geben.
Normalerweise den Nierenstein kommt spontan
in Blasen.
Man braucht keine besondere Eingriffe.
Aber wenn es zu teils groß ist, kommt eine Schuttoswellentherapie infrage.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ich habe hier noch einen Eingriff, der denkbar wäre für die Ableitung, wenn da mehr Steine sind.
Oder mehr kleine Steine, dass man eine Haarleiterschiene anlegt.
Er hat ein einziger Attacke.
Das wäre, wenn es rezidivierend käme.
Ja, würde man das machen.
Die Therapie richtet sich natürlich nach der Größe, wie groß der Stein ist.
Wenn der nicht so groß ist, kann man davon ausgehen, dass der mit konservativen Methoden abgeht.
Dass man dem nur ordentlich Flüssigkeit geben muss.
Und natürlich Schmerzmedikamente, damit er das aushält.
Dann untersuchen Sie bitte Herrn Schläfer gründlich und erzählen mir, was dabei ausgekommen ist.
Dann bin ich gespannt, wie es dem Patienten am nächsten Tag geht.
Ja, gut.
Ja, wer möchte noch etwas sagen dazu?
Das ist gut.
Ja.
Polakisuri.
Polakisuri, genau.
Ja, genau.
Da haben Sie auch irgendwie eine komische Formulierung genommen.
Er hat ja gesagt, der Vater hat eine Gefäßerkrankung und er hat ein offenes Bein.
Und ihm ist eine Großzehe abgenommen worden.
Und da haben Sie gesagt, die Großzehe haben Sie nicht erzählt.
Sie haben nur gesagt, er hat ein offenes Bein und er ist operiert worden.
Da war die Formulierung nicht so ganz australisch.
Und zum Glück haben Sie nachher noch etwas Schönes gesagt.
Und zwar in der Beschreibung.
Der Patient hat jetzt den Begriff der Flanke nicht erwähnt.
Er hat gesagt, es tut mir im rechten Rücken weh, Oberhalt von der Hüfte.
Ich habe bis extra nicht das Wort gesagt, weil es sonst so eindeutig ist, wo das hingeht.
Und dann haben Sie gesagt, im Lendenwirbelbereich, das stimmt natürlich nicht so ganz,
sondern es liegt ja deutlich höher.
Und nachher haben Sie aber, haben Sie irgendwann den Begriff,
der Begriff ist bei der angekündigten Untersuchung, da haben Sie dann gesagt,
ich gucke, ob da ein Flanken-Schmerz da ist.
Also ich denke mal, der Begriff ist sicherlich, der muss fallen in dem Zusammenhang zur Lokalisation.
Also Schmerzen in der rechten Flanke.
Ich weiß nicht, ja, Ausstrahlung haben Sie gesagt, das erinnere ich mich.
Jetzt muss ich gucken, was hatte ich noch.
Sie haben gesagt, im Generalbereich, oder?
In der Leiste und in Genitalbereich.
Ja, aber das waren eigentlich auch die Sachen, die mir aufgefallen sind.
Sie machen ein paar Grammatikfehler, weiß ich aber jetzt nicht mehr,
aber man kann sie sehr gut verstehen, sie sprechen schön ruhig.
Und das ist nie irgendwas, was den Sinn entstellt.
Es ist nicht ganz exakt, wie gesagt, von der Grammatik, aber ich glaube nicht,
dass das jetzt ein großes Problem ist, weil man sie sehr gut versteht
und weil sie auch alles verstehen, was die Leute ihnen sagen.
Ja.
Ich habe Probleme mit der Grammatik.
Ja, manchmal stimmt die Artikel nicht, mit der Grammatik.
Aber das ist natürlich etwas, was man hier jetzt nicht aufarbeiten kann.
Da müssen wir jetzt hoffen, dass die Prüfer darüber weggucken, einfach.
Aber ich denke mal, das führt nicht zu gravierenden Verständnisproblemen
und insofern, denke ich mal, kritisch könnte das werden,
wenn sie in die Situation kommen, jetzt im Beruf tatsächlich,
dass sie selber Arztwürfe schreiben müssen.
Ja, oder einen schriftlichen Bericht machen.
Da ist das natürlich immer ein bisschen besser,
wenn man sehr exakt in der Grammatik formuliert.
Aber beim Schreiben achte ich auf Grammatik mehr, weil ich habe...
Das ist einfacher, das geht langsamer, ne?
Ja, gut.
Aber wie gesagt, was ich sehr angenehm fand,
dass sie sehr ruhig und unaufgeregt das Gespräch geführt haben
und sich nicht aus der Ruhe bringen lassen.
Das fand ich ziemlich gut.